Comment pouvaient-ils tirer des conclusions sur mon patrimoine génétique
si j’utilisais mon origine sociale et me présentais comme une femme noire ?
Après tout, je me considère comme une femme noire dont le père est blanc
plutôt que comme une femme blanche dont la mère est noire
et ce pour des raisons sociales.
Ainsi, ce que j'indique comme origine ethnique
n’a absolument rien à voir avec mes gènes.
Cette question était donc très importante
pour la validité de l’étude
et pourtant on m’a répondu : « Ne vous inquiétez pas,
indiquez l’origine avec laquelle vous vous identifiez le plus. »
J’ai donc coché « Noir »
mais j’étais très sceptique face aux résultats d’une étude
qui ne prenait pas au sérieux une variable aussi capitale.
Cette utilisation de l’origine ethnique dans des tests sur le patrimoine génétique
m’a fait réfléchir :
dans quels autres champs médicaux
l’origine ethnique est-elle aussi utilisée ?
Je me suis rendue compte que l’origine ethnique est très répandue en médecine.
Elle influence les diagnostics des médecins,
les mesures, les traitements,
les médicaments prescrits
et la définition même de certaines maladies.
Plus j'avançais dans mes recherches, plus j’étais interloquée.
Les sociologues comme moi expliquent depuis longtemps
que l’origine ethnique est une construction sociale.
Lorsque nous utilisons les mots noir, blanc, asiatique, amérindien, latino,
nous faisons référence à des groupes sociaux
dont les limites ont changé au fil du temps
et varient selon l’endroit du monde.
En tant que juriste, j'ai également étudié comment
les législateurs et non les biologistes
ont créé les définitions légales de l'origine ethnique.
Il ne s’agit pas seulement du point de vue des sciences sociales.
Vous vous souvenez du jour où la carte du génome humain
a été dévoilée à la Maison Blanche en juin 2000 ?
Le président Bill Clinton avait déclaré :
« L’une des plus grandes vérités
qui émerge de cette fabuleuse expédition
au sein du génome humain
est qu’en termes génétiques,
les êtres humains, quelles que soient leurs origines,
se ressemblent à plus de 99,9 %. »
Il aurait pu ajouter
que les moins de 1 % de différence sur le plan génétique
ne provenaient pas de l’origine ethnique.
Francis Collins, qui a dirigé le projet du génome humain
et qui dirige aujourd’hui la NIH
reprend le discours du président Clinton.
« Aujourd’hui, je suis heureux
de constater que la seule race dont on parle soit la race humaine. »
Les docteurs sont sensés pratiquer la médecine basée sur les faits
et on leur demande davantage de rejoindre la révolution du génome.
Mais ils traitent encore leurs patients en fonction de leurs origines.
Prenez l’estimation
du débit de filtration glomérulaire ou DFG.
Très souvent, les docteurs interprètent le DFG,
cet indicateur important de la fonction rénale, selon l’origine.
Dans ce test effectué en laboratoire,
le même niveau de créatine,
la concentration dans le sang du patient,
produit automatiquement une estimation différente du DFG
selon que le patient est afro-américain ou non.
Pourquoi ça ?
Apparemment, cela serait basé sur l’hypothèse
que les Afro-Américains ont davantage de masse musculaire
que les personnes d’autres origines.
Mais pourquoi
un docteur supposerait-il automatiquement
que j’ai plus de masse musculaire qu’une femme culturiste ?
Ne serait-il pas plus juste et basé sur les faits
de déterminer la masse musculaire d'une personne
rien qu'en la regardant ?
Les docteurs m'ont dit que pour eux, l'origine ethnique est un raccourci.
C'est un indice pratique bien que sommaire,
pour d'autres facteurs plus importants comme la masse musculaire
ou le taux d'enzymes : des traits génétiques
qu'ils n'ont simplement pas le temps de rechercher.
Mais l'origine ethnique n'est pas un bon indicateur.
Il arrive qu'elle n'apporte aucune information.
C'est une simple distraction.
L'origine ethnique est omniprésente dans les mesures cliniques.
Elle empêche les docteurs de voir les symptômes des patients,
les maladies de famille,
les antécédents médicaux et les maladies propres,
qui sont tous basés sur des faits, contrairement à l'origine ethnique.
L'origine ne peut remplacer ces mesures cliniques importantes
sans compromettre le bien-être du patient.
Les docteurs m'ont aussi indiqué qu'ils utilisent l'origine ethnique
parmi d'autres facteurs,
mais de nombreux tests médicaux,
comme le DFG,
se servent de l'origine ethnique comme d'une catégorie
pour traiter les patients noirs, blancs ou asiatiques différemment
selon leur origine.
Ce type de médecine a un impact négatif sur les personnes de couleur
en les rendant victimes des stéréotypes et des a priori.
Les patients noirs et latinos reçoivent deux fois moins
de médicaments anti-douleur que les patients blancs
pour des fractures identiques
en raison de stéréotypes selon lesquels
les personnes noires ou mates ressentent moins la douleur,
exagèrent leur douleur
et sont prédisposées à l'addiction.
La Food and Drug Administration a même approuvé un médicament
spécifique à l'origine appelé BiDil
pour traiter les insuffisances cardiaques des patients ayant indiqué être noirs.
Un cardiologue a développé ce médicament sans penser à l'origine ni à la génétique
mais c'est devenu très pratique
pour des raisons commerciales
de vendre ce médicament aux patients noirs.
La FDA a ensuite autorisé
la société pharmaceutique
à tester l'efficacité du médicament
dans une étude ciblée sur des sujets afro-américains.
Selon cette étude,
l'origine ethnique est un indicateur d'un facteur génétique inconnu
qui affecte les cardiopathies
ou les réponses à un traitement.
Mais pensons plutôt au message dangereux qu'elle envoie :
le corps d'une personne noire est si peu important
qu'un médicament testé
sur une personne noire pourrait ne pas marcher sur un autre patient.
Au final, les déclarations marketing de la société n'ont pas abouti.
D'une part, les patients noirs se sont beaucoup méfiés
d'un médicament destiné uniquement aux Noirs.
Pendant une réunion, une femme noire âgée s'est écriée :
« Donnez-moi donc ce que prennent les Blancs ! »
(Rires)
Si la pratique de la médecine selon l'origine vous surprend,
que penser donc du fait
que de nombreux docteurs américains
utilisent toujours une version actualisée
d'un outil de diagnostic
conçu par un médecin au temps de l'esclavage,
un outil étroitement lié
aux justifications de l'esclavage.
Dr Samuel Cartwright
a obtenu son diplôme de médecine à l'Université de Pennsylvanie.
Il était médecin dans le sud des États-Unis avant la guerre civile,
et c'était un expert reconnu de ce qu'on appelait la « Negro médecine ».
Il a mis en avant le concept de l'origine dans la maladie,
que les personnes d'origines différentes avaient différentes maladies
et ne souffraient pas de la même façon d'une même maladie.
Dans les années 1850, Dr Cartwright déclarait
que l'esclavage était bénéfique pour les personnes noires
pour des raisons médicales.
Il affirmait que les Noirs avaient des fonctions respiratoires plus faibles
et que le travail forcé leur était donc bénéfique.
Il a écrit dans un journal de médecine :
« C'est le sang rouge et vital envoyé au cerveau
qui libère leur esprit lorsqu'ils sont sous le joug des Blancs,
et c'est le désir de ce sang rouge vital
qui enchaîne leur esprit à l'ignorance et la barbarie lorsqu'ils sont libres. »
Pour appuyer sa théorie, Dr Cartwright a contribué
à créer un appareil médical pour mesurer la respiration, le spiromètre
pour prouver la soi-disant faiblesse respiratoire des Noirs.
Aujourd'hui, les docteurs maintiennent encore la théorie
selon laquelle le peuple noir
a des fonctions respiratoires plus faibles que le peuple blanc.
Certains utilisent même un spiromètre moderne
qui possède un bouton intitulé « Race »
qui permet à la machine d'ajuster le résultat
pour chaque patient selon son origine ethnique.
On appelle cette fonction « corriger selon la race ».
Le problème de ce type de médecine va bien au-delà des mauvais diagnostics.
En se focalisant sur les différences innées des personnes face à la maladie,
ce type de médecine détourne l'attention et les ressources
des déterminants sociaux
qui causent des écarts consternants dans le monde de la santé :
peu d'accès à des centres de soin de qualité,
déserts alimentaires dans les quartiers défavorisés,
exposition aux toxines dans l'environnement,
taux élevé d'incarcération
et enfin, subir le stress lié aux discriminations raciales.
L'origine ethnique n'est pas une catégorie biologique
qui crée naturellement ces écarts de santé
en raison de différences génétiques.
L'origine est une catégorie sociale
qui a des conséquences biologiques stupéfiantes
à cause de l'impact des inégalités sociales sur la santé.
Mais la médecine basée sur l'origine prétend répondre à ces écarts
grâce à une simple pilule.
Il est bien plus facile et plus rentable aussi
de vendre une solution technologique
pour ces écarts dans la santé
que de s'attaquer aux inégalités structurelles qui les produisent.
Si j'essaie à tout prix de mettre fin à la médecine selon l'origine
ce n'est pas juste parce que c'est une mauvaise médecine.
J'œuvre aussi pour cette mission
parce que la façon de pratiquer des médecins
encourage encore un point de vue erroné et malsain sur l'humanité.
Malgré les grandes avancées de la médecine,
il existe un manque d'imagination
à propos de l'origine des patients.
Imaginez un peu :
que se passerait-il si les docteurs arrêtaient de se baser sur l'origine ?
Supposons qu'ils rejettent
un système de classification du XVIIIème siècle
et intègrent plutôt les connaissances les plus poussées
sur la diversité et l'unité du génome humain,
c'est-à-dire que l'on ne peut pas classer les hommes selon leur origine.
Et si, au lieu d'utiliser l'origine comme indicateur sommaire
pour un facteur plus important,
les médecins s'attaquaient directement à ce facteur important ?
Et si les médecins rejoignaient l'avant-garde
de ce mouvement pour mettre fin aux inégalités
qui proviennent du racisme
et non des différences génétiques ?
La médecine basée sur l'origine est une mauvaise médecine,
c'est de la science approximative
et une mauvaise interprétation de l'humanité.
Aujourd'hui plus que jamais,
nous devons abandonner cette idée arriérée
et affirmer haut et fort nos points communs en tant qu'humains
en mettant fin aux inégalités sociales qui nous séparent.
Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.